did that make you fail i loved it yeah
you know the kids i used to wrestle with
the kids which of course can't do now
because everybody knows that that would
just be a catastrophe and i used to draw
them pictures of monsters and they'd
line up for that and i liked working
with kids quite a lot and i didn't care
whether it was female dominate i've been
a female dominated my professions my
whole life right i think it felt
marginalized as a consequence well then
you have been lucky and i i have talked
to people who have might be luck the
opposite might be careful can conduct as
well
explain that more to me well why would
you assume that it would be luck
well if i say that you know there is a
statistical analysis and i've talked to
a broad range of people and you know you
always expect outliers at either end
some people who had a really terrible
time some people have had a really
brilliant time everybody else that i've
strived to do is not to become resentful
well okay that's very good i have to say
that your twitter feed does not give me
that impression you come across as
somebody who takes criticism very much
to heart is that true i don't think you
have any grounds for that suggestion i
mean you've seen my interviews online if
i was someone who took criticism at
heart i'd be in a lot more trouble than
i am now in what way
well i've been criticized
endlessly for two years i've been in
scandals i've probably been in i don't
know how many scandals in the last two
years and had unbelievably contentious
interviews with journalists online on tv
on radio in podcasts if i was someone
who couldn't tolerate criticism the
evidence for that would already be clear
twitter's a strange social network i've
kind of pulled myself away from it so
it's not an easy place to conduct
yourself with as much grace as you might
and i think it's it sort of rewards
impulsivity
because it's
maybe it's because of the constraint on
on characters
or something like that
so i think that
people tend to show their worst on
twitter and and and some of that's a
consequence of the of the structure of
the technology i think i certainly agree
with you i think that's something that
we agree on there i think people are
really at their best on twitter no and
you know i pulled myself away from it
quite a lot in the last month
um mostly
for to see why you know i kind of kept
an eye on twitter all the social medias
media networks for the last few years
partly
to see
well i'm trying to monitor
what's happening around me i suppose is
probably the right way of thinking about
it and to see
if i'm making mistakes and how they
might be rectified
but
i don't think twitter's been good for me
and i don't think it's i don't think the
reply function on twitter is useful and
i think the fact that so many people on
twitter are anonymous
is not a good thing at all
do you think you'd be less angry if you
weren't on twitter that's something i
think quite a lot i'd be just i would be
coming to contact with less things that
annoyed me on a daily basis
oh i i don't find him as an angry person
i know i don't know much about him but i
don't find him
as an angry person he's
he's passionate when he starts talking
about what he says and like the
knowledge he knows he he backs it i
wouldn't say he's
an angry person i wouldn't say that he
takes criticism
to heart just based on the two videos
i've seen
he takes it very well but he comes back
at you with some knowledge and he backs
it up so
i think he's just a lot smarter than
these people
and yeah people can people can get um
[Music]
what's the word
like nervous or like just feel like
infuriated when someone is smarter than
them and they're not open enough to
listen to them and understand what
they're saying so they
try to
project or come at them sideways to get
them off yeah and instead of you know
admitting like like all that stuff that
he talked about with the patreon i used
to kind of view the world the same way
like women were like oppressed that's
where taught
literally and it's okay to be wrong but
like when you get all of that
information he laid out for you
like he's not angry he just knows more
than you you can tell he's been doing
this his whole life
and we're like lucky enough that we can
watch this stuff and see a lifetime's
worth of work in these conversations
yeah exactly
i think there's no doubt about that yeah
yeah i i think that's definitely the
case and i've talked to other people
who've pulled back from twitter and
experienced the same thing
i don't know what it is exactly but
there's a there's something about
twitter that seems to really heighten
the desire of people to be provocative
and maybe it's the case that
only people who are feeling irritable
respond you know we don't know you know
like if you put up a post
and a thousand people read it
certainly a thousand people don't
respond a few people respond well maybe
maybe it's skews way over to those
people who had a bad day like we have no
idea right because it's a communication
channel that
no one understands we're not evolved to
understand it we're not evolved to use
it we don't we can't interpret it plus
you're interacting with random strangers
which is something you never ever do and
it's never the same set of random
strangers and you don't react to twitter
like it's random strangers you rack to
twitter like it's a person that you know
and it isn't you write in 12 rules for
life about having had violent impulses
that you didn't act on and i think in
maps of meaning you elaborate on that
you say you fantasize about stabbing a
classmate in the neck and you say you're
very clear about the fact that you you
know you never ever thought you would
take those seriously but it just does
make me think whether or not are you
somebody who
thrives on anger who finds anger to be
something that they need in their life
that they find motivates them to do the
things that they need to do
you
i feel like almost every human has
thought about
hurting somebody
severely or just to an extent like man i
just want to punch them in their face
like just because you think that doesn't
mean you're going to act upon it's just
like you're angry
and
and he's old if he had a history of
violence it would have shown up by now
he would have bar fights or something he
would not be he would not be where he is
if he had a history of anger he would
have been canceled before he even
started his uh his career
goodness those are two different
questions okay you can answer them both
one is
whether i thrive on it and the answer to
that is most certainly not
so i actually don't like conflict
and how have you ended up doing this as
a job
which is arguing with people right just
because you no that's not my job it's
not to argue with people
okay
so my job is to not do things that i
don't think i should do
right and my government made the mistake
of assuming that compelled speech was
acceptable as long as motivated by
hypothetical compassion
and that's not happened for me
so i made that point
it wasn't because i wanted to or because
i enjoyed it i don't really like
conflict i'm actually a rather agreeable
person which is partly why i'm a
clinician
and so
i find the the constant conflict
exhausting
but that's not the issue i'm
you're not morally obligated you're
morally obligated to do things other
than that which you like
so now i really do enjoy the lecture
series that i'm doing
and the reason for that is that it's not
political
in its essence
i'm trying to do everything i can to
bring people who are trying to develop a
vision for their life together
and to encourage them to act more
responsibly but but not in a finger
wagging sort of way
but because i've come to understand that
the meaning that sustains you in life is
mostly to be found through
responsibility and
through the voluntary adoption of
responsibility you're very likely to
find your fundamental strength and i
think that that's
clinically unassailable observation
and so and that's all very good and i'm
very pleased to be doing it and it seems
to be having a salutary effect as far as
i can tell
and but
but it's not because i thrive on anger i
mean you were at my show what two on
thursday night yeah how much anger was
there in that well i thought it was
fascinating because it was in long
island um i drove we drove to it and we
went past a lamborghini dealership a
porsche dealership this is not a poor
area the audience was i would say
very like as i was surprised how many
women there it was pretty mixed it was
overwhelmingly white and i thought you
talked
uh you know you said at the end i was
more incoherent than i normally am you
ranged across quite a range of subjects
from you know status in monkeys to
perception but the things that the crowd
clapped and they applauded where you
went oh you can't say that that's a
microaggression or multiculturalism is a
you know it's a scourge that is sweeping
canada and what i got was the strong
sense that has swept canada okay well
what i got was a very strong sense of
people whose lives i never said that it
was a scourge that swept canada either i
wouldn't have said that okay well i will
go back and check your exact wording on
what you said but you definitely i'm not
in favor of it as a fundamental doctrine
right i don't think it's a scourge so i
wonder if you and i mean the same thing
when we talk about multiculturalism
because you have a first nations room in
your house right you have a lot of first
nation stuff
how is the co-existence of the honorary
member of a first nations family
it's wonderful i have a uh
a first nations artist and when i'm from
when i went to canada last year but that
to me is the essence of canadian
multiculturalism living that culture
being preserved and living alongside the
anglophone culture that in some senses
supplanted it how is that not
multiculturalism well multiculturalism
is the idea that the cultures can all be
put together in a single place with no
overarching structure or undergirding
structures like that's not the case how
can that possibly be the case that
defines the situation in the world
and the world is full of war
so how does how can that possibly work
if you're going to bring people together
and they're going to be and they're
going to exist together in harmony they
have to be playing a game that everyone
plays that everyone knows the rules for
it can't be ten different sets of rules
for different people that isn't going to
work
so it's absolutely naive to believe how
if that worked the world wouldn't be
full of war
well before we had you know
multiculturalism we still did have war
war in fact war is as stephen pinker i'm
sure you read your stephen finger says
yeah this is the least violent time in
human history so something that's a
consequence of working
tyranny well if you think the patriarchy
has been eroded over the last 100 years
maybe that's what it's down to maybe you
could give some credit to it for that
first of all
she
when he asked her a question
she doesn't answer it
she goes on to talk around it but
doesn't answer the question that he asks
what what he was explaining as to what
he does
i'm thinking i'm like
why why is this such a bad
thing like he's helping people
to live from what i understand to live
like the best life without thinking that
oh i have this hurdle jump through this
her to jump through and he's teaching
people
obviously there's going to be hoops you
have to jump through but you don't have
to focus on that like this is the way to
live your life
in spite of all those things and i'm
like why why is that
such a bad thing and the fact that he
he talks with such like knowledge and
calmness and passion it's like
why
like was there did you did you pick up
any anger in that
it's like yes or no yes or no ma'am say
yes or no
and i just don't understand
[Music]
why
why is he getting such like negative
connotation with
because the left is crazy
i believe it in my soul
i don't think they're bad people a lot
of them i think have really good
intentions
but i just think like the second they
like they paint him out to be a certain
way that's just how they see him
regardless of what's in front of them
gotcha that's that's
just my opinion but i also didn't know
what multiculturalism was so i was
really glad he laid that out yeah same
thing
i was like what
but i think he's talking about just like
you can't bring too many cultures
together and not expect there to be
conflict yeah people people find groups
but
um i think it's just like in school when
you bring
all these different people together
they're going to find people that they
resonate with more than others it's like
you can't expect everybody to be buddy
buddy and be friends it's it's just a
life yeah yeah i agree
we'll go for a few more minutes
i actually didn't say that the
patriarchy had been eroded
well you know because you don't believe
existed in the first place fair enough
but my definition of multiculturalism is
citizenship based right so you can be
both canadian and first nations you can
be both quebecois and also canadian uh
you know but that means that everybody
in the multicultural milieu is one thing
and another right they're all one thing
and another yeah yeah well you know our
prime minister said well there is no
canadian identity
it's like well okay what is it that
unites us well nothing we all protect
our cultures it's like well that leads
to war okay that doesn't only lead to
war obviously
but unless you have people
operating within a shared framework of
perception and value they can't
cooperate and compete
uh peacefully
and
there's
i don't understand how that's even a
disputable
topic that's how you organize people
okay i i think if that's what he said
that's what trudeau said that is a dumb
thing for the prime minister of canada
to say when you are prime minister of
canada yeah you might you might say that
i would agree much more with what barack
obama said when he said you know i'm
trying not to make her red states of
america or blue states america or white
america blackmail i'm trying to make a
united states america and that to me the
democrats are very good at that well
they they've played identity politics
for the last 20 years all they've done
is inflame tribal tribal tendencies as
far as i can tell so he can say that but
it isn't obvious that it's the case and
it's not obvious to me at all that one
of the consequences of barack obama's
presidency was a reduction in racial
tension in the united states no i
wouldn't agree with that either i think
a lot of people find having a black
college educated professor very alarming
and threatening to their idea
to stop them from voting for him twice
no that is very true but again it's
fundamentally true right it's really the
crucial issue at hand here no but he
built a big coalition of white
well-educated liberals and people of
color i mean that is that that is the
democrat election how do you explain the
rise of racial tension in the united
states then well i think it's caused by
a lot of things not at least in one of
which is the republican party in flaming
it you talk about the left playing
identity politics i think the right play
identity politics all the time the right
doesn't dominate the universities no but
it dominates but donald trump is
president so real estate trump is hardly
a typical republican no he isn't saying
that he's coming
for most of his life if i remember
correctly he was a democrat right i
don't think he has anything
to blame donald trump
okay but i'm going to say the rest of
the republican party are also quite
happy to play i would say white identity
politics they go they did not dump him
as their candidate when he said mexicans
they're not sending us their best people
here they're rapists right the whole
idea of the united states it said i
think a beautiful thing all men are
created equal but it meant men and it
meant specifically white men women and
black people could not vote the u.s was
founded on identity politics this is not
some new concept that has come along in
the last 20 years the united states
wasn't founded on identity yes it was
that's absolutely absurd proposition the
united states was founded on the same
principles that
um
what would you say that played their
powerful role through the development of
of of english democracy and that was
nested inside a judeo-christian view
that fundamentally presumed that both
men and women were made in the image of
god and that all people had divine value
and it took a long time for that set of
ideas to fully manifest itself in the
political realm but to consider that a
manifestation of identity politics is i
i can't imagine why you would possibly
do that i don't consider that a
manifestation of identity politics i
consider having a constitution that says
only some people are citizens to be a
manifestation of identity politics well
what do you think changed it across time
and then look let's get our definition
straight here
you can't
lump all
occurrences of
uh non-equal treatment into the
category of identity politics identity
politics is a very specific thing it's
really only existed since the 1970s you
can't go back into 1770 and say that the
founders of the american constitution
were playing identity politics they were
politics that was based on identity
that's my definition of identity that's
not the definition of identity politics
unless you play fast and loose with the
definition identity politics is
something that's in no one talked about
identity politics 20 years ago or 30
years ago it's a new term
you you can't say that people's
proclivity to identify with their group
is identity politics that's just
tribalism and that's like who knows how
old that is a million years old
500 000 years old and you're going to
call tribalism identity politics
well that's not helpful if you want to
talk about tribalism we could talk about
tribalism but identity politics is
something that's nested inside a
particular political view of the world
it's got a marxist basis and it
manifests itself in post-modernism and
it emerged in the american in france
first in the 1970s and then has swept
through the american universities and
increasingly the rest of the west since
then that's identity politics if you
want to talk about tribalism that's fine
i'm not a fan of tribalism which is why
i don't like the identity politics types
and i don't care if they're on the right
or the left i think the right wing use
of identity as the primary marker for
human categorization is as reprehensible
and dangerous as it is on the left
my problem with the left at the moment
the fundamental problem with the radical
left is that they're hyper dominant in
academia and that's not good and that's
not my opinion you can go look at
jonathan heights dad and see for
yourself and he's as moderate person as
you can hope to find and probably less
prone to anger than me
i i
i agreed with what
she said surprisingly um i
i still don't understand
the identity politics and i was like
obviously i was listening to him but i
i would agree more with that on what
she said instead of what he said
um
what like specifically is identity
politics
so what he's talking about is tribalism
so tribal so there's identity politics
and i i could be butchered i'm not an
expert in identity so this is just my
understanding
it's like something that kind of started
in the 70s so it's kind of like
you're
it's like using
politics to like
sorry they're going to roast me in the
comments for this definition
for not understanding and he explained
it it's like it's like using politics to
divide people
okay so instead of saying like we're
we're americans they'll be like oh
you're you're a white american you're a
black american you're an asian immigrant
does that make sense yeah and they kind
of like use that to like divide i want
to say but i think what he's talking
about there's a
no i'm butchering that i'm so sorry guys
should we google the definition let's
just yeah yeah google because that will
be you
that'll be the last thing
okay identity
politics okay let's see the definition
is an approach wherein people of a
particular gender race
social background social class
environmental or other identifying facts
develop
political agendas based on their
identities
so that the poli oh so it's like the
politics is based on like who you are
okay so and so i think what she he's
talking about tribalism
which is
like the
uh definition
i don't know i'm the wrong person the
state the state of being organized into
tribes so he's saying that the the us
was based on tribalism and identity
politics is new okay that's what he's
saying okay
but
i don't really have strong opinions on
that because i just i don't think i
understand the definitions well enough
yeah
i would need to look at them a little
bit more just to understand just the
difference between
those two definitions because it they
sound
similar they're so similar they say i'm
like i'm like okay
what's the what's the difference because
they sound similar to me
but um
yeah
i think
go ahead i think like when i think of
identity politics it's kind of like do
you remember when i was arguing at the
table were you there when no i don't
know if you were there when the wnba
player girl was there did you hear that
um
no i wasn't did you see that clip yes
it's kind of like how as soon as i was
arguing something they bring up that i'm
a white woman
instead of arguing with me about the
like like what we're talking about and
we weren't even talking about race okay
he'll bring up like what like what i
look like rather than like talking about
the argument okay and the politics
that's what i i think of i don't know if
i'm right okay